- [Narrator] It's not just you
your daily coffee ritual
is getting more expensive.
If you walk into an
American cafe right now
your average coffee drink is
going to run you around $4.50.
Five years ago, it would
have cost you just $3.85.
Nearly a 17% rise in prices.
That's compared to
inflation, which has grown
around 10% during the same period.
That rise is driven by a
myriad of economic forces
that help determine the
cost of your morning cup.
And now experts say that due
to a major crop loss in 2020
in a matter of months,
prices could go up even more.
We'll explain.
The price of coffee is driven in part
by a complex global supply chain
which shapes a more than
$460 billion market.
Most coffee beans are produced
in Brazil, Vietnam, and Columbia.
They're then loaded on ships like these
and then transported around the world.
This well-oiled system moves the beans
to importing countries like
the US, where they're then sold
to coffee traders who
sell them to roasteries.
The roasted coffee is
then sold to distributors
such as grocery stores and cafes.
Max Copestake is a Coffee Futures Broker.
- The trade operates on paper-thin margin
it's extremely competitive business now.
Things like shipping costs are massive.
- [Narrator] During the pandemic,
the industry has faced a
number of shipping disruptions.
A shipping container
shortage in Southeast Asia
has driven up the price
of many commodities, including coffee.
- Everything is taking longer to get
from one place to the other,
containers are piling up in
places where they shouldn't be.
- [Narrator] Jose Sette is the
Executive Director of the ICO
a leading inter-governmental
organization for coffee.
- It's not just Southeast
Asia, all over the world
we have problems finding
sufficient containers.
So that means that
freight rates tend to rise
and increase the prices.
- [Narrator] Coffee exports
are also affected by storms.
In Nicaragua and Honduras
communities were devastated
by hurricanes last year.
- They caused a lot of
damage to infrastructure,
washed out bridges,
landslides that block roads.
- [Narrator] The destroyed
roads block trade routes.
And this meant the supply
being imported into countries
like the US was diminished.
The concern over a lack of
supply help drive up the price
of coffee futures and experts
say this could continue.
- As temperature increases
this affects the viability
of growing coffee
especially Arabica coffee.
Robusta as its name indicates
is robust, is strong
and is harder to be affected
by climatic phenomenon.
It's very resistant.
But Arabica coffee is more delicate.
It grows within quite a
narrow temperature range.
- [Narrator] Over the past year,
the world's largest
coffee producer Brazil,
faced a drought that devastated crops.
The International Coffee
Organization says that around 30%
of the country's Arabica
crop may have been lost.
This year's coffee
yields will also be lower
because Brazil is in an off-cycle harvest
which happens every other year.
- The off-cycle is small,
and we know that anyway
but this year is extra small.
And this has got people really spooked
'cause all of a sudden everyone's like,
"Hang on.
We need this huge country
because we've become so reliant on you."
- [Narrator] Marex Spectron estimates
that the global coffee market
will produce millions fewer bags
than the previous crop year.
You can see these factors are pushing
up the price of coffee
futures, but overall
the effects of the drought
haven't yet been felt
in your local cafe or grocery store.
With weather becoming more
extreme around the world
due to climate change experts say risk
to coffee production will continue.
- As temperatures increase,
you would expect to find that areas
that currently produce
Arabica will become too hot.
And we have to think about
ways to mitigate this,
whether by different farming
techniques or whether
and this is a more difficult
process, migrating production.
- [Narrator] And as volatile
weather increasingly leads
to fluctuations in the supply of coffee,
demand tends to stay pretty steady.
This is because coffee
is relatively inelastic,
meaning that even when
the economy fluctuates,
people keep buying beans.
- It doesn't change much
if prices go up or down.
Let me try and explain
this in simple terms.
If prices double in your
supermarket next week,
you are likely to change
your habits to some extent.
You will maybe switch
over to a cheaper brand.
You may not drink as much
coffee outside the home
where it is more expensive.
- But it's unlikely you'll stop
drinking coffee altogether.
When the pandemic took
hold in March, 2020,
people were forced to stay home.
Demand for out of home coffee plunged,
but demand for in-home coffee rose
making up some of the
difference in consumption.
And as the pandemic
continued, another pressure
on coffee pricing was playing
out in global currencies.
Coffee future prices are tied
to the US dollar and Brazilian real.
The dollar is a global safe haven
in times of economic trouble.
So during the pandemic coffee
farmers were incentivized
to take advantage of
the strong exchange rate
and sell off their beans.
The result less stored coffee
will be available next harvest
when crop yields are
expected to be unusually low,
this is causing an imbalance
between the lower supply of coffee
and the expected rise in demand.
And this is why experts say coffee prices
are currently lower than they should be.
They say that this expected rise in prices
will affect the entire supply chain.
And in six to nine months
it could drive up the price of
your morning cup, even more.
(upbeat music)